und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend ihnen allen das
erleichterte aufatmen von Millionen
Bahnkunden können wir uns sehr gut
vorstellen angesichts der Nachricht
heute dass der Bahnstreik früher vorbei
sein wird als geplant nach Wochen ohne
Verhandlungen in denen der Eindruck
immer stärker wurde Gewerkschaft und
bahnmanagement gehen sich gegenseitig
auch ganz persönlich in auf die Nerven
heißt es heute beide Seiten strebten
einen Tarifabschluss bis Anfang März an
in den kommenden 5 Wochen soll es keine
neuen Streiks geben stattdessen
Verhandlungen zur Not auch mit Hilfe von
zwei Moderatoren na also geht doch
möchte man sagen Dominik
lesmeister noch ist vieler Orts fast
nichts los an Deutschlands Bahnhöfen
doch der lockführerstreik endet früher
als geplant im Güterverkehr bereits am
Sonntagabend um 18 Uhr im
Personenverkehr am Montag früh um 2 Uhr
zum Wochenbeginn gilt wieder der
reguläre Fahrplan Bahn und GDL
verhandeln wieder in den kommenden 5
Wochen werden wir verhandeln aber unter
Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit wie es
sich gehört und bis zum 3 märz gilt eine
Friedenspflicht das heißt keine weiteren
Streiks bis zum 3 märz das ist eine sehr
gute Nachricht für all diejenigen die
mit unterwegs sein wollen bereits
vereinbart die Zahlung von 1500 €
inflationsausgleichsprämie im März auch
das für die lockführergewerkschaft
wichtige Thema Arbeitszeit soll
angepackt werden GDL Chef wieselski
erklärt dazu insbesondere die
Verhandlungsbereitschaft der DB zur
arbeitszeitabsenkung für Schichtarbeiter
ist zentral
bedeutsam die erste Verständigung nach
Wochen der Eskalation und gegenseitigen
Beschimpfungen vor allem der aktuelle
rekordstreik brachte der gd1 wie Kritik
ein erhöhte den Druck auf Bahn und
Gewerkschaft es kam wahrscheinlich die
Einsicht von beiden Seiten aber der
Druck von außen wurde natürlich auch
erheblich auf beide Tarifpartner auch
wir haben ja beide Tarifpartner
unabhängig von Schuldzuweisungen
aufgefordert im Sinne der Fahrgäste
wieder an den verhandlungstiicht
zurückzukehren bei den Fahrgästen wie
hier in Hamburg Erleichterung gut finden
endlich einigen würden es wird immer
behauptet die die Forderungen bestehen
zurecht aber irgendwo ist auch mal die
Grenze das zumutbahen erreicht bis zum 3
März keine weiteren Streiks und die
Hoffnung dass es bis dahin eine Einigung
zwischen Bahn und lockführern gibt ja es
gab ja einige Appelle doch jetzt endlich
zu Potte zu kommen der
Bundesverkehrsminister war vor drei
Tagen hier im heute journal auch mit
einem Appell seinerseits aber beide
Seiten zeigten sich bis lang
unversöhnlich Stefanie Hein am Berliner
Hauptbahnhof was hat denn jetzt wohl die
kehtwende
gebracht na ja es gehört ja zur
Choreografie solcher Tarifverhandlung
dass es auf solche klaren schönen Fragen
selten so ganz einfache Antworten gibt
und diesmal ist auch noch
Verschwiegenheit vereinbart aber klar
ist so ein strek ist teuer die Bahn
spricht davon dass das 25 Millionen
kostet pro Tag den Konzern so ein Streik
sicher ist es auch für die Gewerkschaft
nicht günstig auch wenn die kein Zahlen
veröffentlicht aber die Zahlen
schließlich für ihre Streikenden
Mitarbeiter Streikgeld die Bahn gehört
dem Bund und der Bundesverkehrsminister
hat ja schon gesagt dass er gar kein
Verständnis hat für diesen Streik und er
hat auch sehr darauf hingewiesen dass
ein Streik auch im Güterverkehr einen
großen wirtschaftlichen Schaden für die
für die gesamte Wirtschaft hat wenn
Betriebe nicht beliefert werden also all
diese Sachen sicherlich in
unterschiedlichen Gewichtsanteilen
werden jetzt dazu beigetragen haben dass
wieder verhandelt wird und das heißt
dann steefanie das ab Montag bereits und
dann auch für die kommenden Wochen alles
wieder normal
läuft na die Bahn hat heute gesagt die
Bahnsprecherin sagte es werden morgen
tausende Züge die umgeplant werden
müssen damit am Montag so halbwegs
wenigstens jeder Zug da ist wo er
hingehört es wird noch etwas ruckeln war
heute die Ansage aber dann soll es
fahren bis zum 3 märz sollen die Züge
fahren so wie sie geplant sind ganz
normal mit allem was zum normalen
Bahnfahren EBO der Zug gehört ja
wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder mit all
den normalen Problemen in
Anführungszeichen herzlichen Dank
Stefanie Hein live vom Frankfurter vom
Frankfurter sage ich schon von Berliner
Hauptbahnhof natürlich so wenn eine neue
Partei Auftritt auf der politischen
Bühne dann stellen sich ganz
grundsätzliche Fragen was haben die vor
was steht im Programm ist das Protest
oder echter Aufbruch und ganz generell
gesagt wo ist die Partei zu verorten
links rechts irgendwo dazwischen beim
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht stellen sich
diese Fragen noch mal besonders deutlich
die Namensgeberin war jahrelang in der
Linken aktiv von denen sie sich heute
abzugrenzen versucht ebenso wie von der
AFD Andrea Maurer berichtet vom
allerersten Bundesparteitag des
BSW für diese beiden ist die neue Partei
wohl auch Vollendung ihres Lebenswerks
zwei Parteien hat Oscar la fontain schon
hinter sich gelassen im
2005 die SPD 2022 die Linkspartei das
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht die Partei
seiner Frau soll nun Heimat sein für
politisch heimatlose auch für ihn der in
einer radikal veränderten Weltordnung
immer noch an die Friedenspolitik der
60er Jahre glaubt Willi Brand erhielt
für diese Außenpolitik den
Friedensnobelpreis und ich würde mir
wieder wünschen dass ein deutscher
Bundeskanzler mal wieder den
Friedensnobelpreis erhalten würde und
nicht für Waffenlieferung für Aufrüstung
ein sten W das BSW will Partei sein für
die die Alternativen suchen bislang vor
allem bei der AFD die AFD ist
politischer Gegner Wählerinnen und
Wähler der AFD aber wollen sie gewinnen
es empört mich immer wieder wenn
kritische Meinung um sie klein zu machen
einfach mal als rechtsradikal oder
rechtsoffen diffiert werden rund 380
neumitglieder sind in das ehemalige
kinoosmos in Berlin gekommen viele von
ihnen hat das Bündnis aus der
Linkspartei rekrutiert sie stimmen ab
über Programm undal gewählt sind sie
selbst
nicht hat den Eindruck dass dieses
Konzept der topdown Partei die von oben
alles in bester Ordnung systematisiert
aufgeht es gibt alle Abstimmungen fast
ohne Gegenstimme man konzentriert sich
auf den kernkanon dessen was auch diese
Strömung innerhalb der Linkspartei
bereits für ihr gemeinsames Credo
entwickelt hat die europaahl im Juni ist
die erste Wahl bei der das antreten will
das Bündnis kritisiert die EU in ihrer
aktuellen Form will eine Begrenzung der
Migration und einen Stopp der
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine um Zitat
Russland zur Aufnahme von Verhandlungen
zu motivieren geht es nach dem frisch
gewählten Spitzenkandidaten wird diese
Wahl einer antiampelwahl die Menschen in
Deutschland sprechen mittlerweile Abend
Stoßgebete aus dass Olaf Scholz ein
Kurzarbeiter im Kanzleramt werden möge
die Ampelkoalition ist die der hilferin
der AFD aber beten hilft nicht liebe
Freundin und Freunde man muss auch
wählen und deswegen ist die Europawahl
eine Chance dieser Regierung eine
deutliche Warnung zu senden die
Parteigründung fällt in eine Zeit
multipler Krisen eine Unsicherheit die
Wagenknecht
beschwört mündet der Umbruch in einen
Aufbruch oder in die Katastrophe alles
ist möglich und wir starten auch jetzt
deshalb weil wir nicht nur zuschauen
sondern weil wir eingreifen und handeln
wollen weil ab jetzt hängt es auch von
uns ab wie Deutschland in 5 oder 10
Jahren aussehen wird Wagenknecht will
ihr Bündnis als doppelte alternative
positionieren zur AFD und zur Ampel wer
wenn nicht wir sagen sich hier mit einer
Selbstgewissheit die sie an anderen
Parteien auch
[Applaus]
kritisieren nie wieder dieses Bekenntnis
gehört zum 27 Januar seit Jahrzehnten
dazu dazu Wehen in Deutschland die
Flaggen auf Halbmast nie wieder
Ausgrenzung und Rassenwahn und Diktatur
und
Massenmord heute vor 79 Jahren wurde das
KZ Auschwitz Birkenau befreit von der
Schreckensherrschaft der
Nationalsozialisten die nicht nur dort
in deutschem Namen unfassbare Verbrechen
verübten in diesem Jahr ist das nie
wieder mehr denn je in aller Munde das
ist einerseits gut weil der Kampf gegen
Anti Semitismus und die Feinde der
Demokratie niemals auf einen Gedenktag
beschränkt sein sollte es ist
andererseits auch verstörend weil sich
Jüdin und Juden auch im Deutschland des
Jahres
2024 nicht mehr sicher fühlen hier sind
ihre
Stimmen ich fühle mich zu 100% jüisch
auch zu 100% Deutsch also ich würde
sagen deutscher Jude mein Name ist nor
Petri ich bin 20 Jahre alt und studiere
Medizin in
Berlin Januar 2024 fühle ich mich als
junger Jude in Deutschland ziemlich
unsicher ich glaube ich befinde mich
gerade in einer Zeit wo sich mein
zukünftiges Leben ob es in Deutschland
ist oder nicht entscheidet undline es
ist im Grunde so dass unter Post von mir
beispielsweise geschrieben wird es
riecht dir nach Gas seit dem Angriff der
Hamas of Israel hat sich einiges in
Deutschland für mich verändert viele
stand im Kontext immer schon zum Spruch
nie wier der zu nie wieder ist jetzt
geändert worden ist ich frag mich wo die
Leute waren als es darum ging dass auf
deutschen Straßen der Judenmord gefeiert
worden ist dass Häuser mit davidstell
markiert worden sind als Jüden in
Deutschland bin ich hier zu Hause und
gleichzeitig immer wieder damit
konfrontiert dass unser Dasein in diesem
Land nicht selbstverständlich ist mein
Name ist Hanne Weiler und ich bin
Präsidentin der jüdischen Studierenden
Union Deutschland ich frag mich immer
wieder wie groß wäre meine Familie wer
wäre ich wenn sie nicht vernichtet
worden
wären es ist einfach ein ganz anderes
Erbe ganz andere Last mit der man
irgendwie auf die Welt kommt und das
macht unsere Existenz hier sehr
ambivalent und sehr widersprüchlich und
irgendwie auch sehr extrem und radikal
die Tatsache dass wir freiwillig wieder
in Deutschland
leben ich unterscheide strickt zwischen
Schul und Verantwortung also die zweite
Generation dritte Generation sie haben
nichts mit dem Schuld zu tun aber diese
Verantwortung dass das nicht wieder
passiert diese Verantwortung gehört uns
allen ich heiße Ron Segal ich lebe als
israelischer Schriftsteller in Berlin
seit 2009 ich bin 43 Jahre alt ich habe
drei Kinder nach dem Beginn des Krieges
war das erste Mal dass ich eine
Polizeibegleitung für meine Lesungen
bekommen habe und das fand ich schon
wichtig aber auch also und ein bisschen
unberuhrend also ich bin ja keine
Synagoge ich bin ein Mensch ich habe ja
deutsche Wurzeln meine Großeltern
mütterlicherseits stammen aus Berlin das
ist für mich eine Familiengeschichte und
ich betrachte meine meine Umzug nach
Berlin als eine Art ruheher der Familie
ich wünsche mir dass jüdisches Leben
einfach als selbstverständlich
betrachtet wird es muss nicht irgendwas
exklusives sein es ist auch keine
Parallelwelt jüdisches Leben findet die
ganze Zeit statt besonders den großen
Städten wir msen Antisemitismus im Hier
und Jetzt bekämpfen es reicht nicht nur
mit toten jüdenen solidarisch zu sein
wie jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
aussehen soll soll ich nicht bestimmen
das ist nicht meine Aufgabe das ist eine
Frage
die unter der deutschen abklären werden
soll was für eine Gesellschaft wollen
sie
haben 3 Minuten mit sehr viel drin zum
Nachdenken Nikola Albrecht hat die
Stimmen junger Jüdinnen und Juden in
Deutschland gesammelt
an diesem Holocaust Gedenktag
2024 so was ist noch wichtig heute die
Antworten hast du kaisö ja und Antworten
ist da schon ein gutes Stichwort denn
die werden immer lauter vom
unpästinenser Hilfswerk gefordert
mehrere Länder setzen ihre Zahlungen an
die UNRWA aus darunter Deutschland
Israel wirft 12 Mitarbeitern vor sie
hätten sich am hamassüberfall vom 7
Oktober beteiligt das hilsswerk leitete
eine Untersuchung ein und und kündigte
den Beschuldigten Israel gehen die
Reaktionen nicht weit genug
Außenminister Katz erklärte man wolle
sicherstellen dass die UN-Organisation
nach dem Krieg im Gazastreifen keine
Rolle mehr spielen
wird in ganz Deutschland sind wieder
ztausende gegen Rechtsextremismus auf
die Straße gegangen allein in Düsseldorf
kamen bis zu 100.000 zusammen darunter
viele Familien mit Kindern vor 25000
Menschen fand Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius in osner Brück klare Worte AFD
Wählern müsse klar sein dass sie
Faschisten wählen auch in etlichen
anderen Städten setzten Bürger ein
klares Zeichen gegen
Rechts mehr als 50 Unternehmen haben
rechtsextreme Kräfte als Bedrohung für
die Demokratie und wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit bezeichnet in einem
gemeinsamen Brief riefen sie die
demokratischen Parteien zum
Schulterschluss auf auch um den Umbau zu
einer klimaneutralen Wirtschaft zu
schaffen dafür brauche es
wettbewerbsfähige Energiepreise eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse und eine
digitale
Verwaltung der frühere US-Präsident
Trump muss der Autorin
egene Caroll weitere
83,3 Millionen Dollar zahlen wegen
verleäumdung das hat eine Jury in New
York entschieden und der Klägerin damit
deutlich mehr Geld zugesprochen als
erwartet Trumps Anwälte kündigten
Berufung an weil er Carol sexuell
rauchte und sie als Lügnerin bezeichnete
war Trump bereits in einem früheren
Prozess verurteilt worden zur Zahlung
von 5 Millionen
Dollar wie immer samstags gibt's die
Lottozahlen 14 20 24 29 33 43 Superzahl
ist die vier weitere Gewinnzahlen gibt's
auf flotto zdfde und im ZDF Text auf
Seite
556 das Wetter wird morgen weitgehend
sonntagstauglich denn bei 5 bis 11°
scheint fast überall die Sonne nur im
Norden wird es auch mal wolkig und an
den Flüssen kann sich teils Seer Nebel
halten auch die nächste Woche startet im
Norden mit einem Mix aus Sonne und
Wolken und im Süden mit Nebel am Morgen
und danach viel
Sonnenschein toll das war unser
infoangebot aus der heute
journalredaktion wir sind morgen an
diesem sonnigen Tag gerne wieder für Sie
da dann um
21:45 uh ja und für lang aufbleiber gibt
es nachher um 0:24 Uhr noch mal den
neuesten nachrichtenstand bei heute
Express 0:24 Uhr angenehmen Abend
[Applaus]
[Musik]
C